The time has come for me to review your submissions yet again.
"What are they gonna disappoint me with this time?" is what I think, every time. Oh no, original content!
Maybe that's it. Oh, it's been looking a little weird, maybe that's it! Last week, I asked you bros,
sisters,
family, to make something in real life,
IRL. Yes, it exists. Now, I already scrolled through, and it looks like most of you failed...
So, good job.
Good job for that, good job. You did it, you really did a good job. Good job. Now, let's look at them anyway.
This is my mental age...
12 years. Let's just start with this one. "Sister-fister." Oh, ok!
So, someone actually did it!
A cute, little-- it's like the Ruby Brofist that I promised that I would give out, and I didn't lose,
I did not lose them, at all.
I still have them very kept-- very safely, and I still have them, okay? I, don't worry about it, but someone just made one!
That's awesome!
It's a replica of this baby. [smooches Ruby Brofist twice]
It's not the real thing, but you know, you try. "Origami Pewdiepie," what? No way. Oh, that's awesome!
What?!
You see the whole process... This better not be a troll. I swear to God, if this is a troll...
What!?
Oh my god!
Kawaii-ne~!
What?! Ah,
Yes! It's amazing! Aw, it's so cute!
That's so awesome! I love it. That's so cool. I thought it was a troll, I legit thought it was a troll. That's so cool!
So cute!
I wanna try and make it.
You have the tutorial. That's so cool. Thank you very much... "pewdiepie the hype beast alcoholic."
Pretty much, yep.
They're all very different, but the very first one I ever tasted was Malcolm, a 12 year old... ah, 12 year old. I get it.
Very nice, very nice. This is all gonna be about the whiskey video? Jesus. I've seen this one, that was really great.
It's really brave of her. Spreading their request/squad fam in the real world. Respect... Phh.
This one took bravery... This one took artistic skill. Hey, what is this, 3D Pewds? Yes!
That is good shit!
I like how you made my beard completely unsymmetric as well, appreciate that. It is not, by the way. It is not.
Unsymmetric. I trim it very nicely. It's so cool though. I love it. Why is my...
Arm so.. Looking like a.. That's awesome. Thank you very much, TheLifeOfChava.
Very cool. What? "Hello random people scrolling through..." What? You did.. Aw, that's so cool!
So, she did a t-shirt design of my old background.
When I actually had effort into my background. It's really cool. I'm glad you guys actually did...
I-- I thought it would all be memes. I thought it would all be memes!
"You have to start by believing in yourself." -Mark Fischbach
"I do everything that I do, for the fans and it means so much to me." -Logan Paul. "You gotta want it...
... No one else is gonna want it for you." -Jake Paul
I like that one.
Her: He's probably thinking about other girls. Him: Is math relate-- God damn it, that fucking meme. I swear to God.
"I found this and thought of Pewds." Oh, okay. Well. They spelled women wrong, so I don't know, that's just kind of embarrassing. No fucking way.
No fucking way!
Yes!
The garçon c'est bellissima! Wow!
It's-a beautiful! Look at it!
You really captured the excellence of Nick Crompton,
just like I did. You really understand the soul that went into the artwork. My God, I...
I'm crying. It is beautiful.
I love this! Well done, R0bs2017.
That's fucking awesome.
God damn it.
"The human eye can expand up to fifty-five percent when looking at something that you love."
I've never seen this meme before, that's pretty original, pretty funny.
Oh my gah!
What is this?"Pewdiepie ohmygah compilation."
OhmyGAH x19
"Please don't copyright this video."
Pfft, god damn it, it got copyrighted. God fucking damn it.
"I couldn't afford original content this year, so I got you clickbait instead." "Accurate shit."
That is so cute. What the-- Oh, whaaaaaaaa...
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!
"Waiter: Your steaks are very rare. Wow that's rare. Recent-" Okay, fuck you, god dammit.
Moving on! Hey, look at this sculpture!
You really captured the beauty of Marcia. My god, look at those legs.
Look at those legs on Marcia. Hell yeah. Hell yeah, if only... If only they looked like that in real life. Oh--
What-- I--
I didn't say anything. Hey, Edgar,
It's you! "Wow, wow, I look, straight up, it looks just like me."
Wow. To be honest, this is really cute, really cool. Appreciate you, E, E, EMD5, uh...
Get a normal name next time. That's cool.
That's really dub, dude. Whoa!
What a beautiful sculpture! My god. Oh my [GAH]!
"niuko-nuuke." Wow, you really captured my soul.
My elegance, my nose, and my eyes. Wow, it looks so good. It looks so good. You really did a good job.
This is going to be worth a lot one day.
I want you to lock this up, put it in a bank or something. Make sure no one touches it because... My god, oh my [GAH]!
That is incredible! Wow! "Sister Fister."
Good job. You know what, I'm really tired of this meme, but you.. You wrapped it up quite nicely.
I gotta say, well done. "When you become an alcoholic because of lack of YouTube revenue." The irony is that I didn't think this video,
would get, would get monetized. I even asked YouTube and they were like "Yeah, probably not." And it got monetized just fine.
It's the easiest one today. I should just keep drinking!
It's like YouTube is like, "Just keep drinking buddy! You're fine!" "This game is har..."
"Needle felted you..."
How do you even do that?
That's awesome.
I like how you got my hairline as well.
It's so cute! Thank you very much, "shawn-wants-2-die"... Okay. Okay, here we go.."birch and.."Oh.
What?
That is so cool! Looks beautiful, a-very nice. Dis look like a beautiful piece of art, the way you cut it out.
Astonishing.
That's cool, though. I would actually like, like to have one of those. That's cool. Appreciate you.
Well, I guess we're twins. How about that?
My long-lost, my long-lost twin brother.
"Mega, Evan McGregor here. It's Evan McGregor here. I took over for Pewdiepie.
This is how I talk, I'm Evan McGregor, fuckin'...
fuckin' McGregor here." Ohh!
This is how I talk! I'm Evan McGregor!
More fuckin' could go has more, but my lace! Go check my knees, and switch your hair with a ball!"
Pretty accurate, good job. "Watch me cover Chop Suey!" "Watch me drink my pain away."
And they said Felix was out of ideas! All right, so what should we do for next week?
What should the next challenge be for you, my squad fam?
Let me know what you should, what challenge you want to do next time. Actually, you know what, I think I just got an idea!
Make a thumbnail for this next week's video. That's all you have to do, just make a thumbnail.
I just got this completely original idea out of nowhere. Wow. Okay?
Yeah, that's a good idea that I just came up with, squad fam.
Thank you so much for watching, squad fam. Appreciate you guys and love your-- what you do.
Squad fam.
Thanks for all the submissions, as always. I really, really appreciate it.
I think my favorite one has to be... Nick Crompton. Anyway, love you guys. Thank you so much.
Squad fam.